hello
can you hear my voice right now this is
this is a test
oh my goodness
oh no guys we're doing a little test
check here
um I'm hoping that it's working
but I don't think that you guys can hear
me which is
which is quite unfortunate so let me
figure out some things
okay wait yes you can hear me oh my
goodness okay okay it's a little lagged
so I was listening on
um
yeah a lot of things are happening okay
this is amazing okay I'm gonna start in
just shortly if you guys still don't
hear the music though
what if I turn it up really loud
I don't know
it's hard to say
okay wait wait
for it
wait for it okay now do you hear the
music
do you hear the music now
do you
know where the heck is the music I
wanted to have a nice little nice little
song for you guys in the background and
it's not
and it's not loading
um hello everyone well we're gonna have
to I guess do without the music
because oh my gosh I have the tracking
on with my camera
I have it
streamed live in so long so you guys
don't have to forgive me for forgetting
how to be a person
um
I'm gonna do my best to
okay no music I still sit under the
music that's crazy because I can hear
the music like I can see the waveforms
they are they're there
they are they are going to town but you
don't see them so it is what it is uh
well thank you guys for joining today
I'm so excited I'm doing a live unboxing
of some digital collectible toys and I
partner with cryptoys uh to do a full
video and I told you guys in that video
that I was going to do a live unboxing
um
okay is my tracking back on so we're
about to do the live unboxing here but
before we get started I just want to
make sure all of my tech is working
because I'm normally I had this all set
up to stream to like several other
platforms and streaming on YouTube is
completely different so I had to
completely redo my whole Stream So I am
very hyped though to to get started and
to chat with you guys look at this I can
move my webcam with
um I think I have a green screen on
my webcam because it is seeing through
my webcam for the green over here do you
guys see that
I normally have my green screen but I
didn't want to put that on either
let me yeah
see here
get this all set up how's everyone doing
volume is low
is the volume low
can you hear me we can turn it up look
at that hello is that better
is that better I gotta see these
microphones you have to stay so close to
it oh my gosh hi Emily I don't know how
you do so much live streaming I'm so
impressed I feel as even as a tech
person this feels so stressful to me I
just I used to stream so much so doing
this
um
not as frequently like it takes a while
to get back into the groove
okay let me fix my webcam so that it
doesn't think that I am on a green
screen
and
then we're gonna we're gonna do some
unboxings I'm gonna redo my intro so for
anyone joining that they will understand
what is happening so let's edit my
filters okay so check this out so I have
the chroma key on so if you watch the
it thinks that I'm on a green screen
from my my monitor back there oh color
correction we've got a little color
correction we've got some crop action
happening it's like you're watching
Justine discover her computer for the
first time
it's great we're going to turn off
the chroma key
hello hello
you guys can hear me you can see me I'm
actually using the insta360 camera it's
their their webcam and it works really
well so super hyped about it
I'm still upset that you guys can't hear
my music
I'm gonna try again and see if
am I moving around does everything look
okay if you guys see something that
happens that seems a little sus just
shout it out from the rooftops and let
me know
okay let's see if this music works we're
gonna try again
like the music says it's playing and
it's really upsetting
that it's not working so we're just
going to keep trying and hoping for the
best so okay friends Hello friends
family
you don't understand the greatest tech
vloggers oh no so there is
I love this comment they're like I don't
understand how the greatest Tech vlogger
is having Tech issues there is just
something about me and live streams when
um when we go live like I would always
play video games with my friends and
no matter what they would always be
waiting on Justine to fix her stream
and it doesn't make any sense
um the live is talking about where
habiting is happening very shortly here
I mean you clearly see that I'm live
I just want to make sure that everything
is working before we get into it
oh man I have a whole new
to be posting shortly so it's going to
show you the redo of my gaming setup and
everything so it's it's it was a big
overhaul so I still haven't actually
reset up all of my things how I like
them
uh but we're gonna get started here very
shortly so to anyone joining hi hello I
am Justine welcome I'm gonna tweet this
out really quick so that we can have
some friends from Twitter join us
um all right
Friday evening chill session
okay
you guys hear that music yet
do we hear the music
we don't hear it do we
like about like at this at this point
I'm just gonna open up
the epidemic sound and turn on some
music so you guys can hear it
I think I know what happened actually so
I'm using
the road caster
and it's um
there's like 500 settings that you can
add like multi-channel audio outs and if
I have the chat on here
that's okay as long as you guys can hear
me you can see me
that's all that we could ask for
I don't have a P.O box I just I don't
want any things I don't want any I have
too many things and I have a problem
with clutter and even though like they
could be cool things that you guys could
send I I don't want you spending your
money on things that you would send to
me I appreciate it I do love though
meeting you guys in person having
meetups and stuff like that and getting
really cool fan merch like you guys
always make the coolest things I've got
so many awesome little goodies from you
guys but I definitely don't want you
buying me things or sending things
um I just appreciate the support online
like it's it's all that I could ever ask
for
so
um Gabriel thank you I appreciate it
um I can't believe in watching for that
long that's amazing
you guys are the best
oh my gosh you guys are sending little
tips
thank you brocky's thoughts I appreciate
it and then who oh we have a member
um oh my gosh you just joined the IJ
Army holy moly I see you guys using all
of the little Maddie emoticons in the
chat like this is awesome
okay I'm gonna send my tweet out and
then we're gonna get this party started
I also want to do a live q a
at some point talking about some of the
things from WWDC so we will focus on
that not in this stream because there's
so much to be said and so many questions
that you guys have that need to be
answered
um okay we are gonna go I'm sending the
Tweet out right now
sweet okay cool okay Hello friends hi hi
hi hi the stream is officially starting
now should I do like a okay here we go
look starting soon
oh my goodness Hello friends it's
Justine here I'm super hyped because
today we're going to be unboxing some
digital Collectibles and this is so so
exciting because they're actually Star
Wars themed and for some of you guys who
don't know I am a huge Star Wars fan
like I am just so hyped about this now
cryptoys is a digital toys platform they
also have a bunch of other digital toys
and collectibles already but this is
their first Star Wars drop now it's
really neat because some of the other
cryptoys that they have now like you can
actually bring these toys into different
types of experiences so the neat thing
is when you get the toy it actually acts
like like if you went to the store and
you bought like a toy and
like a little a little package
um you can have the choice to keep it in
the package or you could unbox it and
today friends okay we're gonna unbox
some I have a couple I'm probably gonna
have to buy some more because I'm I'm
kind of excited about this and I want to
see who I get so let me go into my
unboxing
okay did it work do you guys see are we
here is it happening I think it is
um so here's the website now this is the
entire crypto okay so I'm gonna have to
like I think I have to log back in let
me see if I logged in yes I am logged in
so
the Star Wars drop is super special
because okay we're getting teleported
right now everything is happening
um
obviously being a Star Wars fan when I
saw that they had some digital
Collectibles I've actually already
unboxed a few so these are the ones
these are actually still in their little
bubble wrap so I wrapped I didn't wrap
them they were they were wrapped
digitally but you can unwrap them and I
haven't actually unwrapped these yet so
I'm gonna wait to unwrap one or two of
these I kind of want to save them and
that's kind of the choice that you have
to make like when you get these it's
like do I want to
actually unwrap it or do I want to save
it because there are
um for a lot of these toys like in the
future there's going to be a Marketplace
so you'll be able to trade and sell them
and do things like that so right now
that's not available yet but when it is
you know you're gonna do you want to
keep it wrapped or do you want to unbox
it it's kind of that same thing like in
real life and I am never a person that
keeps collectibles in like their their
packaging like shoes toys like no
they're getting opened up but I saved
these ones so that I could give you guys
the the whole unboxing experience so
when you go in
you'll buy these holocrons so here they
are I've got five here that need to be
unboxed so these ones I don't even know
what they are yet so you can see it's
like those mystery bags like when you go
to the toy store and you always you buy
those and then you don't know what's
inside and I'm
like I absolutely love this it's one of
my favorite things like me and my sister
it was like our favorite pastime to go
and unbox oh I would mostly be doing the
unbagging and then I would send her to
the checkout with my credit card to go
and buy more and then I'd be sitting on
the floor in the toy store like ripping
open these bags feeling them it's wild
it's so it's so wild
um gamer friends is wondering what
Maddie is doing Maddie is he's just
hanging out he is a good boy that is my
dog for those of you that don't know
um
Spenny Benny is asking what MacBook I'm
using I'm actually just I'm using a PC
right now for all my streaming stuff I
always do stuff on PC
so that is that is that so if you guys
have any questions feel free to leave
them in the chat and yeah so what to buy
one of them they are 39.99 but then if
you buy five you get a golden ticket and
that will give you access to other drops
so I'm hyped because I haven't unboxed
these ones yet and we're also doing a
giveaway so in the description below
we're going to be doing a giveaway at
the end of this week so you guys can
click that to get more information
and hopefully some of you guys here in
the Stream will be able to win one and I
can't wait to see uh what you guys get
um okay
oh my gosh somebody said I didn't even
was Mr Mr Evian says I didn't notice
this was a live stream I thought this
was a video and I was like oh this video
looks nice nope it's a stream it is I
actually do miss live streaming I need
to really spend some time and set up my
stream a little bit better okay let's
get into this we're gonna unbox I also
have a little cheat sheet here that I
have prepared because when you unbox
these they are from specific films and I
don't want to mess up which ones is from
so this is exciting because I can show
you guys exactly which one I get which
film is from and I'm kind of hoping we
get an ultra Grail which is like
that's the one you want there's only a
one percent chance there's a one percent
of ultra Grail there's nine percent of
Grail and there's a twenty percent
legendary thirty percent rare and forty
percent common so all of these are the
same price but then you unbox them and
you can get
a different level
um hi Travis how how are you good to see
you oh my goodness it's like I keep
randomly seeing like some of my friends
popping into the chat because everyone's
like wait you're doing a live stream
this is exciting
um Travis I hope you're doing well uh we
gotta we gotta get back into some jiu
jitsu
okay let's unbox
our first one
okay here we go
okay so the unboxing experience is
actually really cool
um
the thing so I can't actually play the
music and the music and the sound
effects is really what makes this but
because it's copywritten music I don't
want to get my channel taken down
um so we're gonna just let me know if
you guys do hear this music because then
I actually have to stop this music
because this I can't play because I
don't want my channel to get taken down
or get a copyright strike I love that
like the music that I was trying to play
wouldn't play and the music that I don't
want to play
it's probably going to play and let's
just fingers crossed and hope for the
best okay are you ready are you ready
okay here we go
let's
oh no okay here we go
here we go okay so we just got
teleported now this is always so scary
I'm like oh the action cannot be undone
here we go we're tapping and holding
um so you get them on the cryptoys
website
here we go here we go here we go here we
go here we go
let's unbox you
I wish you guys could hear the music so
it's playing like the Star Wars music
and then it just kind of like beams up
oh my God we got another Leia okay I'm
so hyped about this because I already
got and it's a legendary oh okay so okay
so this okay oh my gosh I can't believe
it because I'll have to show you guys my
entire collection I've already got a
couple of Leia's and this is a legendary
so that is the 20 scarcity and this is
Leia from A New Hope do we open it do we
open it
I'm gonna open all of them first
and then I'll decide which one I want to
do for the unboxing because oh my gosh I
don't know why should I should I should
I do it should I do it should I do it
let me go see let me go see him okay
so this is it's cool because you can
actually get the stats of each toy so
there is a limited amount of these so
they they do actually sell out so like
once they're gone they're gone and these
are the first edition so this is number
uh 1422 of 2 000. I don't want to unwrap
it yet I want to I just want to like
look at them all in their on their shelf
here
look how many layers I have my the one
that I'm most proud of though is this
one because this is number 354 of 2000
and oh my gosh I love that Emily and
Travis are chatting chatting in the chat
okay
so let's do another one
and then I'm gonna show you well
actually should I unbox one of these let
me unbox a common one unwrap one of
those
let's see okay
I had no I have a duplicate I kind of
want to keep her in her wrapping because
she is a very low number
so let's do oh my gosh
have to decide
this one is this wall gosh I'm stressed
out I'm stressed out she okay she has a
higher number so we're gonna unwrap her
so I'll show you guys the entire
experience
okay unwrap
I can't wait till there's like full
experiences where I can actually play
with them so if you don't unwrap it
it basically just stays still
but then
here we go unwrapping unwrapping and
wrapping
so you guys can hear it because it's
copywritten
um but the blasters are playing they're
Star Wars music happening and there she
is the thing that I like about this is
there's I've
when I you guys probably would be
if you guys were my parents you would
probably like just seen you have spent
way too much money on digital
Collectibles not just this platform but
other ones and I have seen a lot of
things and why I'm so hyped about
cryptoys is because they actually have
really great art and the entire team
behind them just hearing their vision
for this entire platform was something
that I was like I want to back this I
want to be a part of this and I'm super
excited about it because I have bought
so many other ones where the art is not
very good there's not actually a
platform and there's no real future so
that's why
I'm most hyped about this
okay
um
let's Okay so we unboxed her
let's go do okay so now look at her
she's out she's out and ready to play
she's out of her packaging all right
let's do another one
I wish you could hear the music there
are Star Wars music here now it's
playing
yeah George no the detail is like they
really
they really did it okay
it's happening it's happening it's
happening so you can buy one holocron
for 39.99
oh here we go
it's all just I can sing you guys the
music oh we've got a Luke Skywalker and
he is our legendary do we unwrap him no
because I want to go see his details
first
so this is
um our Jedi Knights number 431 of 2000.
okay Emily and Travis if you guys come
visit me
um yeah well definitely we gotta hang
out so it's clearly not going to be a
surprise now that I'm reading about it
in the chat so
all right so we can see our stats of
course this is the first edition
um this is number 431 of 2000.
this one
I'm gonna go back and see him in
all of his glory
so this is great because I also have
got a hero Luke I've got the legendary
Luke I love this one though this is a
rare Leia and I also love my rare Darth
that's actually Anakin so okay let's do
another one
begin unboxing
I wish you guys could hear the music
okay what's cool about these two is like
the fact that like it's digital like it
can be updated it can be upgraded they
can always add new things to it
here we go What's it gonna be oh my God
I want I'm hoping
oh oh yeah oh my goodness all the stores
are so sick look okay we got a legendary
one let's check our details
this is the damaged helmet and this is
the
um
259.
um cat I I have said the price actually
several times uh 39.99 for one and then
when you buy five you get a special
little golden ticket and that gives you
access to other future drops so this
might be I'm unwrapping this one
I'm doing it because this one is my
favorite
damaged helmet Darth oh here we go here
we go here we go
he looks so so good
like look at the detail though like they
really
I wish you guys can hear the sounds the
sounds are the best part well it's not
the best part but it definitely adds to
the entire experience okay back to my
backpack so I have now unwrapped two of
them let's do another one
yeah I love this one as well Lindsay
here we go here we go
yes Emily you have to I hope to see you
guys
I won't be at VidCon but
I'm here
okay what is it gonna be
oh another Leia dude I love that I'm
collecting like every Leia in the entire
universe
the thing that I like about digital
collecting is
um
I have a lot of
physical toys and I'm running out of
places for them
this is 1600
1602 of 3 000.
yeah
do I want to unbox her oh my gosh okay
let me go back to my I'm gonna go back
to my backpack and let me see because I
don't want to unwrap all of them
but like then again I do I can't believe
how many layers I've gotten like this is
awesome
so okay so I have a legendary Leia two
legendary layers
two rare
I've got a common Luke
okay let's hope we can get what do I
want I would like to have a Grail layout
to just really round out this
lay a party that I'm having
is Jenna in here
Jenna hello
hello my friend and sister
Jenny you gotta get yourself a toys
here we go we're unboxing unboxing oh my
gosh okay
like I get so nervous
I cannot believe it oh my gosh another
Leia this
she is my soul sister for sure
okay
let's see she is 443.
so exciting okay let's open let's unwrap
another Leia I think
okay so we have
okay this is I'm trying to like think in
my mind like which one
which one do I wanna open
[Music]
I kind of want to open the Luke
okay let me just okay I'm gonna switch
over because I don't want you guys to
see my credit card number but I'm gonna
I'm gonna buy five more so we can do
another one
um
hello Jenna my sister she is in the chat
this is great I haven't I haven't talked
to you guys I've actually haven't seen
Jenna in a while we've been on separate
coasts recently okay
pardon me while I do a small bit of
shopping
um
here we go
if you guys have any
questions feel free to leave them in the
chat
okay we're going to and I know that the
website's called cryptoys but you you
buy it with money like it's not crypto
you're buying it with cash
I'm buying it right now with my credit
card
Magic
um let's see
I I forgot my credit card number like
the last little digits the security so I
am
hold on a second okay we are ready now
shopping shopping
Aiden says how are you I am doing very
well thank you
okay we have completed
you guys are watching live shopping
right now
okay backpack is in session we are set
um
here we go here we go oh my gosh I love
seeing so many of you guys who are in
the IJ fam
with all of your icons um how many do I
have now Jenna um it's a good question
I doubt
here we go
I think I have five
10 probably 15 now
okay here they are
oh you guys were asking about the other
um drops that they have so they've got
Master of the Universe wave one and two
and they've got these cute little Zoo
the Genesis series like they're the
cutest little things ever and they also
have the master of the universe we have
three
so
let's let's go back in
now you can also choose to not unbox the
holocrons like you can keep them like
this
but clearly that's not going to happen
we're gonna open
who wants to who wants to bet that we're
gonna get I think we're gonna get Luke I
think that
it's gonna be luke here we go
take a guess
what do you think
Luke Luke Luke Luke I'm using the force
course worked oh my gosh we have a rare
Luke let's check out his details let's
check out his details
146 if three thousand oh snap okay this
is great this is this is oh I want to
unboxing but I don't want to unbox him
yet
okay let's do another one a one of one
would actually be pretty sweet but that
would be the ultra Grail and there's um
they look so good if you want to watch
my YouTube video I posted
I can't let you guys hear the sound of
the unboxings because they're it's all
copywritten music
sadly
okay let's do it let's go let's go let's
go
the force is strong with this one I
think that this is going to be
I think it's going to be a Darth
let's go
I'm using the Darth energy we're on the
dark side the dark side has taken over
me
oh another Luke okay I'm not mad about
like I'm not mad about any of them let's
see his stats one three nine seven of
four thousand
he's a common I think did I I think I
already had a common look let's see
yeah I do I already have one
so let's see we've got one three nine
seven
and one six three like he's a super low
number so we're definitely gonna keep
him so let's unbox
let's unwrap him one three nine seven
here we go unwrapping and wrapping and
wrapping
the music is so good
and the lightsaber sounds oh there we go
yeah James there are no one of ones
there's just like a percentage of Rarity
um
so like the like I said the so the ultra
Grill there's one percent The Grail
there's nine percent legendary 20 and
rare is 30 and common is 40 percent
no R2D2 yet Superstar money
I I hear you I see you I definitely have
some requests
for the next drop
oh it would be so cool if they did like
a Droid
drop so it'd be like R2D2 oh my God bb-8
so good C3PO it could be incredible
okay what do we want what do we want
what do we want let's let's let's hold
out for
I mean I I just want another Darth one
to be honest with you
Dark Side Vibes Dark Side vibes
feeling it
let's go
okay yeah Chewbacca will be pretty cool
oh my gosh another
okay this is we
wait does that say does that say Grill
does that mean wait no that's okay I got
I got nervous I saw a Grail and I was
like wait is that Ultra Grill no it's
just the grill I almost panicked
which we're completing our
our Leia series what do we have I think
that's our first
is that our first Grail yes holy moly
658 of 900.
dude this is sick okay so I think we
have all so we have Alaya Grail we've
got the Leia legendary
lay a rare do we have a Leia common
did I open Leia common
what no I didn't
so we still need to lay a comment which
is kind of wild the fact that I've
gotten
wow
wow she's oh we're keeping her in her in
her package
oh man I got nervous
like I don't want to click something
that okay okay oh man okay holy moly
that's exciting I can't believe it I
feel like my luck here has been so many
Leia's that
like it just we now now I'm like hoping
for like a common layer just to complete
or or inventory
here we go
um High dice yes it is it is live
my text is so small on my screen
I'm like squinting this is what old age
gets you
they always say
just wait one day you're not gonna be
able to see okay I'm there
oh another way
of now all we need is an ultra Grill
Leia and we'll have the complete set
I'm so nervous I'm so nervous we have
one laugh we have one left Okay so we've
got
common layout here she is oh my gosh
this okay I got a common Leia but she is
number three of four thousand
dude that's
that's like I don't even I don't I can't
do the math fast enough to figure out
what that percentage of
like I don't know just disregard I don't
like math and I'm not good at it but I'm
very hyped about this and I know the
three of out of four thousand is pretty
incredible wait this is like I got a
common Leia but like she's a rare Leia
because she oh wow wow okay
okay we're doing another we're doing my
last one three or four thousand is sick
I'm not opening it I absolutely will not
Superstar do will not be opening that
one am I gonna have to buy five more and
do this again because I'm I'm having so
much fun
Friday night let's get wild
I literally only planned on doing five
of these and now here we are this is how
this is how this is how it happens
Luke okay we've got a rare looked we've
already I believe we already had yes we
do already have you but let's see your
numbers
to 2 384 of 3
000. I feel like we cannot probably
unwrap him did I what if I unwrapped so
far we didn't
we've got okay so we do have two
oh yeah that 146 or three thousand yeah
we're gonna unbox
this one
the music is so good
so good
oh like you got his little Blaster and
everything
sick open them until I get an ultra rail
okay I'll either be here
I don't know all night or until my
credit card company says Justine what
are you doing
all right so I'm gonna
I'm gonna do
I'm gonna do one more
okay how do we feel about that
how do we feel is anybody against that
yeah you can't hear the music I can't
hear the music because it's copy written
and I'll get in trouble and I won't be
able to have my channel because they
will it's copyrighted
um yeah I definitely would love if they
did in Ahsoka drop that would be so sick
so sick
okay let's do let's just do let's just
do one more
here we go here we go okay
I think my credit card's already saved
now which is
which is a great thing
here we go all right just let's just do
one more
you guys like I
you got to hear the music I'm sure
somewhere
someone has it posted that they
shouldn't with the music but
I'll tell you what it's it's so good
doing a little shopping how's everyone's
day Emily what are the chances Justine
buys more well the fact that my screen
is full screen right now
that is probably a good indication that
I am
doing something
oh okay don't worry about copyright
Emily will defend me in court
all right you heard it here first
um I will if I'll give you an ultra
Grail Leia in return for the legal fees
okay here we are this is this is the
last one
this is the last one because I actually
have to go film a video after this and
it is Friday night and
I gotta go get wild
okay
here we go
oh cryptoys did a video yesterday so
anyone can hear the music that's awesome
um here we are
my friends we're back in my backpack and
I just want to say
oops
I mean
whatever leave me alone leave me alone
I'm gonna do what I want I'm an adult
and these are the things that I choose
to spend my money on
what I don't even know what I want
anymore what do I want I would like to
I want man I want a Grail
Darth because it's the
from The Empire Strikes Back okay let's
oh my god let's Okay please please
please Grail Darth Grail Darth okay we
got a common Darth it's fine it's fine
this is like the traditional
uh Darth which is probably like actually
my favorite okay 184 47 1847.
um okay let's see how he Stacks up to
the rest of my friends
see so I did he was two did I unbox 259
why did I do that did I mean to do that
I think I wanted to keep him wrapped but
I was so hyped about it I just clicked
it's okay
I think no wait is that I
did I not have a common
I didn't have a common Darth
I
Did unbox It For My unboxing but I had
to use uh like mystery ones so I I
didn't actually have those go into my
accounts this is exciting I thought I
already had a common Darth but I didn't
oh God it just looks so good let's just
look at him let's let's unbox him let's
unwrap him come on
here we go
the music is so good
I should have brought my My lightsaber
out
even all the reflections and stuff like
on his helmet looks great
okay okay
we did that
let's let's see what we get
here we go
oh we've got another Darth oh and he's
oh we got a rare Darth okay let's go
back look the most exciting part is
going back and like seeing his stats
okay
1611 of 3 000.
he is cool I keep forgetting what I have
so I need to go back okay so I do have
two of those so I'm gonna unwrap let's
see I will unwrap
um potsy says I don't know what I'm
watching so I'm unboxing digital
Collectibles from Star Wars and
that's what I'm doing
look at that look at that saber
oh yeah do that little spin
so good so good
what do we got how many more do we have
my last three
I need to I need to set a limit for
myself but
because I want to buy some more later
so I don't want
to buy them all now
okay here we go
the unboxing is happening I wish that
you could hear the sounds there's like
this really I love the clicking sound of
the holocron as it's like
disassembling
and we have another common look let's
see his Stats come on come on come on
okay it's about you know Midway Midway
see how does he stand up with the others
that I have
common
I'm like doing
math in my mind of like what a do I want
to unbox him
okay here we go
and we're being teleported into
[Music]
our holocron
oh another Leia
let's see her stats
665 of 4 000 that's still pretty low too
what do we got
I just keep going back and like looking
because I want to see
I want to see my little Shelf
yeah so we almost have the whole layout
we just need
I can't believe I got a grill I'm just
gonna look at her
look at her she looks great do not
unwrap I'm not unwrapping her we're
keeping her in her in her container
all right we have one more guys
one more so again if you guys are just
joining I just did a big unboxing of all
of these digital Collectibles from
kryptoys and there's a link in the
description if you guys want a chance to
win one of these you'll win the holocron
and you can do an unboxing of yourself
and you can actually hear
the music because I couldn't let you
hear the music this is the last one I'm
so I'm so nervous
dude anybody say anything about nfts I'm
a huge nft fan I'm a huge collector I'm
a part of a ton of projects and I don't
like I'm
I believe in the technology behind nfts
the blockchain and one day nfts are not
going to be called nfts You're not even
going to know what it is you're just
existing and
being
using the internet and it's going to be
using blockchain Tech so I mean love it
hate it I've been a fan I've been a part
of this community for
I mean almost like two years I feel like
when I first started getting into the
space I even actually hand Drew an
entire collection of uh nfts that I plan
on dropping at some point uh which I'm
super excited about because I literally
spent three months last year
January February March actually almost
four months and
like completely Drew everything from
hand did the entire process I think
there was like a 10 000 collection but I
think I might actually make it a little
bit lower
so that I can do like two editions and
then add on I don't know anyway there's
so much I don't really talk about it
that often but just know the behind the
scenes like I love this space so much
and that's why I've actually chosen to
really talk more about cryptoys is
because their platform is so built out
and their roadmap for things that they
have planned like it's it's so different
than anything that I've seen over the
past couple of years so I'm excited
about it you guys don't have to be
excited about it but it's something that
I truly believe in and I'm hyped so I
think it's more just see it for yourself
I'm not telling you what to do I'm
showing you things that I like and I'm
excited about it
so let's open our last holocron
What's it gonna be What's it gonna be
like I'm nerd I get I'm actually like
before I hit unbox I start like sweating
a little and getting a little nervous
another layout dude I can't believe it
I've gotten so many layers what's gonna
be really cool is when we actually will
be able to trade these like I can trade
with one of you guys like if you got a
Darth that I wanted a common or whatever
like we could we could swap them and
that's what's gonna be awesome about
this platform later on when you can
actually do these things but this is
still early and I'm so excited that you
know as a tech person I love getting in
early on platforms
um so it's been super fun so let me
figure out I want to unwrap one more
before we
before we do this okay
um
which one should we do so Layla Layla
Layla what Leia
I love her hairstyle too it's so cute
okay so we we're definitely not
unboxing her because she's Grail so we
have a common
Leia where's our other comment did we
did I already unbox the comment
did it yeah it's okay so let's unbox a
common Leia so she
is three uh-uh stay in your stay in your
lane girl you're staying in your little
container
and I'm going to
let's do
six I'm doing the math
we want to keep her
keep her wrapped keep her wrapped
288 is still pretty low
I'm gonna unwrap
six
65.
here we go
so good
so good I wish you guys hear the music
it's so awesome
and there
my friends we have it
um you guys are saying that I don't talk
to the chat I've been talking to the
chat throughout this entire live stream
so maybe you just need to maybe have
some some better commentary
um Edward I know I am streaming on
YouTube this is very unexpected
um
V for Vicky just seems iconic for hey
hey you can ask IJ I do plan on doing an
Ask IJ video so I will be tweeting that
out
and then you can reply to that so I'll
be doing that soon well thank you guys
for watching this was super fun
um I appreciate you all and if you guys
enjoyed this let me know and I can maybe
do some more another day because it's I
always kind of forget about live
streaming but it's so fun and I would
say it's like it's kind of easier than
making a full YouTube video because I
don't have to edit it I just hit the
button and you go live and I get to chat
with you guys so that's really fun
um thank you guys so much for watching I
will see you in my next video there's
all the information below if you want to
get more info on kryptoys and their Star
Wars drop and if you want to enter for a
chance to win some of the holocrons so
you guys can do the unboxing experience
for yourself this was awesome
um I will see you
in my next video so that's it maybe next
time I'll be able to get my music to
work but no promises